content
[Music]
Alex what are you doing I'm just working
here what are you doing at my desk
I'm actually done here so I'm done
no
no Alex all my files are gone what did
you do your time's coming you Clockwork
elf demon gay frog that's what I've been
saying this whole time demons
I want to hear you rip it right now yeah
absolutely yes
[Applause]
ribbitious
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
that is a wonderful sip uh hey uh really
quickly just as we're coming in right
now live on CNN
looks like there was a shooting
including a police officer six victims
in Louisville yeah uh so we'll uh we'll
get to the I guess at the bottom of that
or we'll see what breaks as we do this
live so obviously you know people people
will uh Will Mock this but obviously our
prayers to the families all of those
affected because
that's all we can offer right now people
say oh shouldn't we react no no no we
don't need I'm learning about this right
now because CNN just turned on and that
is not a time to create policy but we
did have a lot that we were planning to
get to today and I don't know if we'll
still have time to get to all but
depending what's happening with
Louisville but I don't know if you know
this Mario crushed at the box office oh
good yeah that was so that's a silver
line that's a happy story not so happy
Riley Gaines was assaulted this weekend
and um we're going to put together here
we'll have and we will not be able to do
it on YouTube so if you're a watch oh
that's right we're back on YouTube for a
little bit oh come on but we're not
going to be on YouTube a lot today we
haven't figured out the rules yet well
there are no rules so today once we do
this we're putting together the
definitive transgender Hit List meaning
activists who have assaulted who have
committed mass shootings a lot of you
kind of know the science behind some of
the comorbidities that come with it but
we actually have put together a
definitive list so you can reference it
and you have that kind of at your
disposal which we cannot do on the
YouTube and we will also be talking of
course about um Daniel Perry in Austin
who was just convicted
for what the detective and what the
evidence said was a rightful shoot and
the governor of Texas says was a
rightful shoot in self-defense but
they're railroading the guy so my
question for you are you know what do
you think my question for you is bad
grammar right off the top it's a rough
day you dummy you smooth brain us to
myself what do you think the
implications are for the country with
the rise right now of trans violence and
the emboldening of it we're seeing a lot
of it and uh I don't expect this to get
to get better unless we start getting a
handle on it I mean assessing the
scenario realistically not just under
the guise of of Tolerance
um as though that necessarily means
Compassion or empathy Gerald is CEO
Gerald a how are you sir I'm doing well
sir how are you I'm good I'm distracted
because of the shooting I was just in
Louisville and you know it's it's not a
nice place no no it is not that's right
Yakuza was there too he echoed very
quickly no no no no yeah totally happy
happy Easter happy Easter on a brighter
note that's true from the grave yep
exactly I do not deserve it at all when
I think of the horrendous crap that I
have done yeah and that you know that
Jesus was crucified for me like I'm like
oh I feel I'm like I'm not supposed to
feel bad we're not supposed to have the
guilt right but I do I'm like oh just I
remember what I did when I was in 14 of
you know four not fourth eighth grade
when I was 14.
and the pictures I looked at well are
those the worst of the offenses no
they're not the worst of the offenses
certainly not no I did some stuff during
the 30-hour famine at youth group to the
church orange juice that frankly could
have killed people lucky yeah and uh you
know him you love him we'll be talking
about what's going on in Austin so uh he
came out we're always happy to have him
in third chair you can go to Mad
maxworld.tv to watch them I'll be
broadcasting from here today at noon
Alex how are you sir it is always great
to be here my friend and you even came
up with your own headset because you
don't like headphones
that's right I mean I'm ugly enough so I
don't get off my phone I look like
Princess Leia with headphones you look
good with yours over there well hey I've
not sliced my nose open today that's
true did it heal up nicely yeah it did
did you have to go to the doctor no no
not that bad you just did a little bit
of the thing the thing the the tape yeah
good and you're not sick
no I was sick when I was here last time
I feel very good today I'm good yeah he
was he was sick as a dog but I couldn't
miss this the biggest show a political
talk out there well we appreciate it and
yeah last time he was like he comes just
so you know I was just last time I was
sick I wasn't trying to be rude not
shake your hand I I didn't know what I
had I'm like it's fine that's fine he's
a very thoughtful guy he's a Teddy can I
it doesn't hurt your image if I say
you're a teddy bear does it no I'm oh
thank you very much you're a nice guy
very nice guy all right so before we
move on to all of this before we move on
to that oh God China's about to invade
Taiwan but no big deal sorry go ahead
what wait
you're a Chiron is this is this we know
it's been I mean this has been festering
for a while do you mean there's actually
been like David circled it and they say
they're ready to go and the word is the
the think it's starting to blockade
basically in the next few months that
leads to War I know that's not on The
Hit List just thought I'd mention well
that's in the next few months Alex we're
talking about today yes
we'll have months to get to it
you're right war with China a little or
no of course going to get to it Alex
all right this is a great start Monday
no we've talked we talked about that
actually when Ukraine Russia uh happened
you know a lot of people don't realize
that depleting our Reserve depleting our
stockpiles when there actually is a
United States national interest when you
understand you know the security of
Taiwan considering how Reliant we are on
them for chipsets eighty percent of the
chips yep that's a really like 80 of the
world traffic goes through that straight
yeah it's a serious but I know that's
for when World War III officially starts
next month no come on okay look he's all
right this is like the tailgater for
world war three yes exactly we're just
all hanging out having some beers no Bud
Light No Bud Light dingling by the way
they committed suicide I know I know or
seppuku have you seen the video of the
woman that was their PR person she said
I took control of Bud Light the last
year and I just thought this would
energize and make it glowing and new and
loving yeah shut up man how much you
want to bet that in her Bud Light can
was white claw oh yeah I'm a hard
Seltzer kind of lady I also said I got
to tell you that the ads were offensive
before oh yeah no of course the
masculine ads yes well Budweisers have
to Clydesdale Bud Light they had they
had the Bud Light ladies yeah and now we
have um penises we have late with ladies
ladies and exactly right yeah because
you wouldn't why would you want to
appeal to your Target demographic but
again it's very obvious that Mulvaney is
is is trolling everybody I mean it's
it's a crazy comedian you think so you
think it's an Andy Kaufman no it's 100
Andy Kaufman really oh I bet Mike I
haven't heard this is that so Bill Hicks
all right so uh on that topic before we
get to everything else uh here is a
woman uh a a woman uh who thinks this
doesn't understand the actual definition
of blasphemy
if you're a homophobe get off my
page okay if you're a trans folk get off
my phone page if you're a racist get off
my page well let's just if you think
it's cool to threaten people with the
idea of Hell get off my page
yeah yes I am doing blasphemy yes
and I am ready to go to hell
well if that was Jesus I'd be sitting
there with the crowd of Pontius Pilate
yelling crucify him but the good news is
that's not hey if it wasn't bad enough
to have Mulvaney as your spokesperson
see sales tax 70 in just one week now
we've got people blaspheming Jesus on
Easter great idea Bud Light I don't
remember thinking it's glass it's just
someone dressed up as Jesus no I know
but I'm just saying we're not Islam Alex
I mean come on no Alex isn't by the
point Alex is making is valid but I
don't think anyone here is a Christian's
offended I'm not saying we want to like
Stone them to death or no or or burn
them or hang them at the soccer stadium
right yeah all I'm saying is the left
this is their Target demographic literal
one ten to one percent freakazoids
yeah no I think so too but I think they
misinterpret like Christians get like
we're not offended at that it's just
lazy it's like yeah remember there was a
Bible burning challenge that was
happening yeah I remember going like
well fine you're the one going to hell
like you know your wish is your command
I mean I want to be clear I think you
should be able to do whatever you want
under Free Speech yeah but I have a
right to them say that that'll make me
dislike Anheuser-Busch products even
more yeah that's absolutely I'm not sure
that that was an official sponsor
Christ ever saying Bud Light no no but
that's who they're targeting well Jesus
did turn the water into wine why now
we're on the same and in the name of
Jesus I want to drink some liquor we'll
have some afterwards wait wait
Jesus didn't distill anything yeah I
don't think water is great that's what
they said I did get up at 3 A.M to get
out here they didn't put uh they didn't
put vinegar extra studios here on the
beach they put Bush ice awesome right on
the beach right here I love it okay have
a drink of water like Bush ice Smite
them
the curtain just tears and it reveals
banquet all right
by the way this is a live show Monday
through Friday 10 a.m Eastern uh and uh
you guys can watch on there's still one
month free of monthly I guess there's
one more week free yeah this week and
into next week Lottery
the Friday show Nick depalo show starts
today well you can go I don't know
people can go watch okay let's get to
Mario here really quickly uh are you a
Mario fan were you would you play it uh
yes I was not a huge video game guy but
from about the age of eight to about 12
or 13 that was a huge video guy and that
was the game that I you know would
Dominate and win it over and over again
and literally spent sometimes five six
hours eating uh Hot Pockets yeah and
honey buns and uh drinking uh gallons of
Coca-Cola that must have been before you
were anti-mon Santo
no no but I mean seriously there's not a
chemical that exists in nature in that
diet well I was also taking mushrooms
while I was doing it oh really wow at
eight yes
no I'm joking in the arcade
I don't think I ever took mushrooms
while playing Mario Brothers but I have
taken mushrooms yeah you just do it one
live broadcasting
well
once once you said right once uh I've
done it with Mike Tyson yeah yeah that's
right that's what I was thinking about
yes yeah oh gosh Mike Tyson was come to
my house we'll do the toad tomorrow yes
you love it you'll Crush you you got a
prior engagement Mike yeah I don't know
I was a little intimidated by that oh I
can imagine Mike Tyson's actually
intimidating person he's not that tall
but you know it's a solid muzzle he gets
out of this murdered out black
Rolls-Royce she's like had to take the
mushrooms with me
laughs
I got toes at home
that sounds like I've had literal
nightmares that start that way oh boy uh
so here's something good news though
Mario Brothers just set a global opening
weekend record for animated films
377 million dollars on a 100
million dollar uh budget
um and let's uh uh I think yeah we have
a clip actually from uh from the film oh
I got this no problem
come on Mario our big adventure begins
now ah get it up get it up get it off
all right uh do we have the do we have
like a Lego zombie clip we have both of
them yeah okay good so I'll run the
other one first so here's the thing this
is a good example of uh you know there's
a disconnect between the critics between
the average viewer right
um we have uh Pixar in Disney remember
light year yeah that took a terrible one
uh I believe it was 200 to make taking
how much did it take in globally 200
million dollars yeah what did I say you
said 200 which would have been oh yeah
come on yeah bring up overlay b c n b c
200 million dollars to make and how much
did it make it's domestic opening 5.6
million that was its Global opening
Global opening week Global opening yeah
not so good and Mario did 377 million
some would say that's more oh my gosh
everybody knows it's going to be endless
lecturing that's why Top Gun did so well
yeah and they're not even right wing
they're just lead people alone and let
them have a fantasy that's why I can't
watch anything on Netflix now it's all
brainwashing everybody knows that but
that's my same question why is
Anheuser-Busch committing suicide why
did Hollywood commit suicide why is the
left doing this why are they like
kamikazes well it's because of the ESG
right score and because of the what's
the other name a component of the ESG
the index where it's basically about
BlackRock Vanguard right they're looking
at these stocks and they're basically
trying to manipulate people into fitting
their agenda it's not about the consumer
it's about artificially manipulating the
market so they can create the world and
this I'm sounding like you know on their
own vision so exactly the banks have
weaponized the
eyes destroyed but it it's a weapon so
they don't mind destroying the NBA the
NFL all these things because to get the
agenda because once the Central Bank
digital currencies are in and once uh
they have those ESG systems in where
everything is tied to your behavior it's
Mark of the Beast total control it's
game over yeah and they don't need to do
anything with soccer because it's
already there so the Mario Brothers
movie though by the way this is a good
example it's not even necessarily uh
anti-woke it just shuns the idea of
trying to be woke so obviously the voice
actor Chris Pratt who's a known
Christian I believe he's more
conservative he said this he said this
is the soundtrack to your youth you
don't want someone to come along and
cynically destroy it I fully understand
that you do not want that to happen and
by the way critics did not like the
movie he can look at the contrast
critics had 56 percent whereas the
audience had 96 percent let's read a
quote here from a Critic said it's a fan
service above all else regressively so
this is Eric March structuring a
threadbare story around iconography
linked to Source material just isn't
enough it's uh it's it's based it's it's
a video game and by the way it's not
even a video game with a real story when
you go back to it okay from the series
of books it was about Mario and Luigi I
don't think I mean can you have two
hours of sorry Mario the princess is
another Castle oh what are you
gonna do like it's just in fact that's
more the reason they're starting to
develop a story on a clean slate it
makes it interesting in fact I'm gonna
go take my daughter to it I'm she's six
I'm gonna check it out because everybody
knows that Pratt is not even really a
conservative but he's not a communist so
people also go because they know that
and it shows what people are hungry for
no you're absolutely right and I think
really you know what you guys share the
rumble show by the way out there hit the
share button
um or the rumble button whatever it is I
don't know but I'd love to hear from you
comment below if I think conservatives
out there you're not necessarily looking
for just a you know hard right or or you
know right-wing content conservative you
just want to know that you're not being
sucker punched right when you go into a
studio like oh when I do stand up right
I'll have openers who are not
necessarily conservative they're just
not anti-conservative yeah and they get
they they say this is the best audience
just because I know that I'm not going
going to offend people all the time well
it's actual comedy it's not a vehicle of
people over the head right exactly I
have people who are I wouldn't say
liberals but sometimes people open who
are just kind of down the middle and
they're like oh this audience is great
it's fun I don't have to walk on
eggshells they just want to know that
you're not going to go out and go aren't
Christian conservatives stupid right
there was a comedy Witch Hunt when
George W Bush was president by the way
people know there's a backlash Joe
Rogan's new club the mothership in
Austin you know sells out like 600 a
ticket every night and I've been there a
few times and the whole thing is
basically anti-establishment so
the warmest turn it sure I was there
earlier you were there earlier you know
before everybody else kind of got on
board but I think that's a sign of
canary in the coal mine for the left
that hey your studios are collapsing
your brands are collapsing your Force
feeding isn't working you need to give
it up well and actually speaking of that
and trying to force feed and committing
his own career suicide really kind of
this was a self-inflicted wound from
John Leguizamo he was complaining uh
about the casting not being diverse
enough and went through a whole woke
tirade we have a cliff of John leguizama
[Applause]
well that is stopping right there uh I
think we actually have oh I think that's
the wrong one right clip
they could have included a Latin
character like I I was groundbreaking
then they stopped the groundbreaking
yeah I was groundbreaking they messed up
the inclusion they did they mixed up the
inclusion I'm I I'm gonna include a lot
of Latinos in the pests too you
know technically Latin comes from the
Romantic language of the Romans and so
Mario brother he is a Latin character
yeah if you want to get technical about
it but I'm hoping that they're going to
do a menu number three with a cover me
in mushroom sauce Burn Me Alive how the
hell does he think he was groundbreaking
I was groundbreaking and making the
shittiest films of all time
[Laughter]
I remember as a child watching The Pest
was the movie that made me realize you
could I could just because when you're a
kid you like every movie and I saw the
past with John Leguizamo and I said this
is so bad I'd rather be doing anything
else and then or it was before or after
I don't know the sequence the same with
the Mario film that he did I'm going
wait a second about king cooper has a
blonde ma what's going on in this way
that they're not even what is happening
it was so bad and the worst part is the
lack of self-awareness he thinks people
are like yeah like with zamo it should
be more like your Mario film nope
so let me give you a few fast facts here
again not diverse enough okay first off
like you were saying yeah to have the
romance languages but you know Italians
like Mario and Luigi if she's talking
about aren't actually Latino in the way
that he would mean it so I don't know
why you would cast him that way but
Princess Peach also was not only white
she makes Larry Bird look ethnic and she
was voiced by an actress who's
Argentinian another fact Bowser I don't
know if this is a dragon in a turtle
shell and this movie is based off of an
eight bit video game and another key
fact which interested me and shows you
how out of touch John leguizano is with
the average Latin American CNN pointed
out some startling statistics regarding
viewership of this film also a racial
element here look at this what shares
Hispanic 41 of Mario film goers were
Hispanic versus just eight percent of
the US media so the fact is the U.S
media is not representative of the
people who are actually going out to see
these films and that's why I think we're
seeing this very large by the way 39 of
them were just using the film as a
babysitter but look progress is fair
exactly I had that when I went to a
movie and it was a it was a rated R film
whoa and uh you know like they they have
you'll see a lot of Latin Americans I
have kids running through them like
really at the ring two
it's a hateful eight yeah kids will
sleep well Mama I want a more Whopper
and Gobstopper and Cynthia
or do you end up like number seven
watching Hannibal okay
so uh actually here to discuss this more
we have uh Super Mario in studio uh wow
thank you for being here um
um I guess Maga Mario is this is this is
is that how you identify now hi Stephen
yes uh uh I don't understand the
controversy yeah okay well John
Leguizamo so that your film is not uh
diverse enough do you care to comment on
that I am from Italia yeah he was made
in America it's diverse yeah okay I
guess that kind of makes sense you know
it's kind of a global in a positive
sense it settle settles settles it for
me Alex do you have anything
no I just think that you're a hero to
children everywhere especially you know
for the people that are in the
psychedelics and the mushrooms yeah oh
that's right it's dap the mushrooms what
kind of what kind of mushrooms yeah what
kind of do we know what kind of
mushrooms that he's on what is wrong
with this man I don't necessarily know
that either what's wrong with you Mario
okay yeah that's fine that's just you
know what happens if you take those I
was just joking you see interdimensional
elves demons what do you think the big
monster that you're battling came from
it was you taking it you're living in a
hallucination you've had a psychotic
break
this man needs help yeah okay all right
no you need help Mario okay let's just
this is again drug Pusher get the hell
out of here okay all right
well you know what they've learned
we've learned our lessons you just cuss
it Mario yeah he's a drug Pusher he is
he's a left-wing pervert
look if that ain't a Pinot mustache
there ain't one okay that guy rubbed
around a white man in your neighborhood
what do you think the mushroom stands
for Stephen yeah where does it occur
mushrooms it's a lovely Mario always be
polite that's the only rule
I didn't think it was weird that he had
a paneled van I thought Mario could you
know why don't you just transport him he
was like trying to give kids candy on
the parking lot yeah well I don't
necessarily I think that was just role
playing I don't I don't necessarily know
what's going on there but we spare no
expense with the Wardrobe hey if you're
watching on YouTube hit the like button
comment all of that because it helps
with the algorithm we were suspended
from YouTube for the first week and uh
of course this is going to happen again
uh hold on Alex
um really really quickly so before
that's Mad Max world.tv right it's where
you're not streaming later not it not at
noon Eastern uh not at all correct no
not at all not not at infowars.com not
at mad maxwell.tv that gets around the
sensors and links no do not watch me
host from your Studios and run on the
wall again no exactly he's not he's
unemployed he doesn't do a show at noon
at Mad Max World dot TV so we have
breaking news a little update on the
Louisville thing if you want to bring up
the CNN feed here the shooter is dead
they took the shooter down we got word
of that a few minutes good good yes
that's good guess what a good guy with a
gun showed up the shooter I don't know
if I'm assume it's a police officer at
this point but we'll find find out later
so five dead six are taken to the
hospital there's one officer that was
killed I think so far and one officer
that's injured but we don't care about
how or why or what is going on quite yet
so we'll keep you guys updated as well
here's the thing and this is like
there's a lot of speculation and people
say oh thoughts and prayers how about
you do something how about you don't
react impulsively and emotionally here's
the thing whether it was a police
officer whether it was a good Samaritan
or whether it was the shooter themselves
committing suicide either way this
person was stopped with it's the only
prediction that we can make that we know
will be correct with 100 certainty the
shooter was stopped by someone with a
gun maybe a knife but I doubt it yeah by
the way pull up the if somebody can find
it in the control and pull up that David
Hogg tweet about uh the people good guys
with the gun stopping it he actually
said that line and said that's stupid if
that was the case then we would fight
for we would fight fires with
flamethrowers we need more flamethrowers
not realizing that that's exactly how
people fight forest fires is with other
fires there's a picture of a guy with a
flamethrower
don't you fight fire with water and then
someone said actually let me explain to
you about controlled Burns I was like
yeah
Fight Fire with Fire but again I learned
alert wasn't an arrogant chinless prick
I remember like 15 years ago read an
article about they ought to you know it
was the Texas Tribune or something they
need to ban the Mexican setting fires
down in Mexico you know that's going to
burn things down no that's why they
don't have the fires because they quote
rake the forest like Trump famously said
they made fun of them right it's the
same thing in Europe they do control
burns then they use all the time they
use the ashes then to plant crops
because that's what they need to grow
that's important for topsoil too
absolutely that's why when a lot of
people are surprised they say they're
actually more more trees right now on
Earth than in recorded history it's
because we've done a lot of work to
preserve trees but we also haven't taken
into account the idea that trees often
those fires they rage and they take that
entire forests and we've stopped them
entirely by building fire breaks roads
are natural fibers right yeah yes in
fact that's statistically true there are
more trees now in 2023 I think like 30
40 more than when
they started keeping records yeah
exactly it's insane well a big part of
it too is because we've become more
efficient with farming right everyone
had their own farm so they would have to
clear for farmland and now not everyone
is a farmer some people live in cities
but also we're far more efficient we can
yield a lot more from from the land so
yeah that's another effect I don't know
how we got here but yeah more trees
never recorded history oh David Hogg the
dog flamethrower I love that now he's 18
now right yeah so is better so you can
make fun of them we got suspended on
YouTube for making fun of Greta thunberg
I think she was seven she was 17. come
on man yeah the internet is in a very
different place does anyone out there
comment below you remember the Olsen
twins countdown clock
when they were 17 it was one and by the
way just so you know before at the time
I mean the Olsen twins are my age right
so I think they're so it was like it was
like teenagers who were like 19 and 20
are going oh the Olsen twins are going
to be 18. it was a joke it was satire
but now you can't even tease Greta
thunberg when she's up there asking us
how dare we how I got suspended on
Twitter it wasn't for the reason they
later expanded and exaggerated and
basically made up what I said it was
because I confronted Oliver Darcy the
the minion of Brian stelter yeah with
the Blaze and then he was at CNN or he
still he's waiting to go in a committee
room that was by the committee attacking
me by name they would let me in and I
say how dare you go around and try to
police and get me off the internet and
they're trying to get me off Twitter man
that's really Un-American and they said
I bullied him that was the final strike
yeah yeah exactly you bullied him by
confronting him he's trying to remove we
had the uh the David Hogg picture oh do
we have the David hog picture let's
bring this up the only thing that stops
a bad guy with a with a gun is a good
guy with a gun well if that's the case
why don't we just replace all our fire
extinguishers with flamethrowers Wow and
then they say that right is reductive is
back burning this is like controlling
fires backwarding involves small fires
along with a man-made or natural fire
break there's a guy with a flamethrower
right there just that's the most
effective that's what stops them you
guys know yeah oh yeah and it's also
better for the environment because they
don't have to take a bunch of water and
use a bunch of fuel to go up in one of
those planes I don't Grant his point but
he's even stupid in making that point
it's like he's a very dumb person yes
well he wants to attack me on C-Span and
said Jones is a horrible profiteer he
talks about how there's poisons in the
water and then sells water filters that
those are ads where we're like look most
Water Supplies are toxic you need to
filter it we sell a filter that's high
quality highly rated that's the whole
point of an advertisement it's like we
have good tires we make they've been
rated really good for your car you want
our tires right it's like he thought it
was like some weird conspiracy a
straight sale to people because it's not
like he's profiteered off of uh you know
mass shootings and he doesn't show up
every time there's a camera even though
when you're talking about the shooting
that took place and then do big
fundraisers he does nothing with yeah
exactly wait didn't he launch it like a
my pillow competitor yeah yeah like five
minutes no it's my pillow biter
did not do very well
he did yeah
good pillow it was a good pillow I think
yes it's the good pillow that's what it
was not a good pillow yeah nothing like
being a you know a calming bastard that
actually tries to make money off of
people selling a product well then he
found out I remember his tweet he was
saying it's really actually a lot harder
running a business than we thought so
like we're not able to do this guys you
don't know how much work goes into this
like everyone who dislikes you does
because we actually work
it's fair all right so hey uh here's and
tomorrow by the way tomorrow's a special
installment it's actually um we don't
necessarily run the teaser but tomorrow
um we're going to be discussing Muhammad
Ali it's going to be a super video
uploaded on location yeah the untold
history a lot of you believe that
Muhammad Ali uh was an anti-right Wing
you know he was an anti-war uh leftist
activist and you may not actually know
the truth about Muhammad Ali how we
changed and evolved later in his life
when he rejected the teachings of
Malcolm X and the Nation of Islam and
actually campaign for Orrin Hatch and
Ronald Reagan wow and actually had a
very close relationship with Donald
Trump so he went from racist liberal
activist to conservative compassionate
activists later in life and I think it's
a story that a lot of people have not
heard so that'll be uploaded tomorrow
and there's a lot of work that's gone
into it and let me tell you this right
now guys we actually cannot discuss what
we're about to discuss here on YouTube
today because it is the definitive Hit
List uh in response here to I guess sort
of in relevancy to Riley Gaines being
assaulted a lot of you see this and you
feel like you're getting tired of seeing
these stories because it happens Ad
nauseam but I often try and think of
okay what is it that you right now
watching listening really could use that
you feel as though you're equipped uh
and I think you probably would like to
to have a laundry list right have an
actual definitive list of these assault
when they've been committed who
committed them so you can reference them
at will and also understand maybe why
there is some science behind the fact
that these assaults are being committed
at a disproportionate rate from the uh
the transgender leftist activists so the
problem is
we cannot do this on YouTube there's no
way we had two strikes technically three
but only two and we were suspended we
just got back on here we have not heard
a response from YouTube yet as to why so
they can suspend us at any given second
so you know the the it's like sticking
your ding dong in a light socket you
cannot talk about the holy church of
transgenderism it's science my question
is either how small is your ding dong or
how large are your light sockets because
either one is uh I have the largest
micro penis in North America
I mean you can at least at least could
you use a gumball machine you got to use
a socket
um all right so right now hit share if
you're on YouTube like
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]